dass die niedersächsische stadt hameln
verdammt grün ist und einen ganzen
haufen richtig schöner bäume hat sieht
man eigentlich auf den ersten blick aber
im hiesigen rathaus hat man die zahl der
bäume irgendwie völlig unterschätzt als
man ein gutachten in auftrag gab
schlappe 9300 82 euro sollte es
eigentlich kosten weit gefehlt
am ende kostete die hamelner baum
zählung das 14fache stolze 130 tausend
euro er wird sammer gehandelt und dann
wird gedacht ja also ich denke mal ich
wusste gar nicht wie früher ich hatte
überhaupt ist und zu guter letzt war das
holen grüne überraschung würde ich mal
sagen
natürlich ist das eine riesige summe die
dafür ausgegeben wird und ich finde es
auch nicht gut dass so viel geld dafür
investiert wurde
eigentlich ist so eine baumschutzsatzung
eine gute idee
die verwaltung registriert die
schützenswerte bäume in der stadt auf
öffentlichen und privaten grundstücken
so wird verhindert dass jeder wild
fällen und herum sehen kann wie es ihm
gerade so passt höchst erstaunlich ist
aber dass die stadt hameln von der zahl
der bäume
überrascht war wir sind von einem
anderen baumbestand ausgegangen weil wir
eine andere zeit zugrunde gelegt haben
die etwas veraltet es im nachhinein hat
sich herausgestellt dass die zahl der
bäume nicht bei ungefähr 800 liegt
sondern bei 16.000 unter jeder baum
einzeln begutachtet und abgerechnet wird
explodieren die kosten für das
beauftragte büro wird aus einem kleinen
auftrag plötzlich ein richtig dickes
geschäft da ist der stadtverwaltung aber
ein grober fehler passiert oder
allerdings haben wir das bei der ersten
abschlagszahlung gemerkt dass da einiges
nicht ganz so hinkommt mit den summen
und dementsprechend haben wir versucht
gegen zu wirken und der gutachter ist
uns dann auch nochmal entgegengekommen
hat ein bisschen was alan price
nachgelassen
mit anderen worten eigentlich hätte es
noch mehr steuergeld gekostet in hameln
schlagen die menschen die hände über dem
kopf zusammen
wahnsinn behandeln das kann man sich ja
normalerweise müssten sie das ja selber
bezahlen jetzt ne wir müssen ja auch
bezahlen wenn wir einen fehler machen
müssen für gerade stehen wir dazu
schreiben
das geld aber noch woanders investieren
können nach 1000 oder 13.000 oder sonst
wie viele bäume sind ist eigentlich egal
so viel geld für ausgibt erschließt sich
nämlich immerhin hat die stadt hameln
jetzt auch gutachterlich bestätigt
bekommen ja sie ist sehr grün und ja es
gibt viele schützenswerte bäume dafür
allerdings 130000 euro zu löhnen
das dürfte auch den berühmtesten
hamelner einfach nur ärgern